foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and A
Song of Ice and Fire update video in
this new video I will go over every
single Game of Thrones show HBO has in
development as you all know the original
Game of Thrones series is still arguably
the most successful show in history ever
since the original show ended over three
years ago HBO has been developing a
number of new shows based on George RR
Martin's incredible A Song of Ice and
Fire Saga for nearly a decade Game of
Thrones had the hearts and imaginations
of millions and millions of fans all
around the realm when you have a show
that reaches that level of international
success it would be foolish not to
follow that up with another show set in
that same universe and that's exactly
what HBO and George R Martin are ready
to do if you have been following all of
my videos then you will know that HBO is
working on a lot of different shows
since Game of Thrones ended but how many
of those are actually still in
development I'm sure most of you already
know they were making a show about the
white Walker's origin during the long
night it was the first idea they had
After Game of Thrones aired its final
episode however they ultimately decided
to go with a different show now a lot of
fans are wondering what other shows does
HBO still have in development what will
we see in Westeros or essos after this
well before I get into all of that I
have to let all of you know about this
amazing new offer I would like to thank
the sponsor of today's video Highland
titles Highland titles is a very unique
gift company that has been around for 16
years and for less than fifty dollars
they can make you a lord or lady they do
this by allowing you to buy a piece of
land as small as a square foot in their
gorgeous Highland estate this makes you
a legitimate owner of Scottish land
allowing you to claim the title of Lord
or lady for years we have been hearing
some of our favorite characters refer to
each other as a lord or lady and now
with Highland titles you'll finally be
able to become one yourself the best
part is that not only will you become a
lord or lady but you'll also be helping
to preserve the landscape as Highland
titles manages the land as a nature
reserve now according to TripAdvisor
Highland titles Nature Reserve is one of
the most popular nature reserves in the
country as the holiday season approaches
or for any other special event such as
an anniversary highlandtitles.com allows
you to give your loved one an amazing
and truly Everlasting gift once you
order your gift from Highland titles you
are your loved one will receive a
personalized official certificate and a
beautiful gift package in the mail as
well as access to the online dashboard
where you can download your certificate
view images of the land and if you ever
come to Scotland visit your own little
piece of Scottish Countryside in the
Highland titles Nature Reserve this gift
already has over 14 000 reviews on
trustpilot with a very high average
rating of 4.8 out of 5. by visiting
www.highlandtitles.com and using my
discount code tt20 you will receive 20
off everything on the site don't miss
out on this amazing offer and once again
I would like to thank Highland titles
for sponsoring today's video alright now
outside of the main series Game of
Thrones and its new successor Showhouse
of the Dragon I think the number one
show that's making the most noise right
now is the Jon Snow sequel series as of
right now I think this show has the most
fans behind it because it's directly
connected to Game of Thrones HBO still
hasn't made their own official
announcement but what we've heard from
Amelia and George R Martin is this show
will follow Jon Snow after the events of
the original show not only is Game of
Thrones actor Kit Harington making the
show himself with his own writers and
directors but many other actors from
Game of Thrones have already went on
record saying they would love to come
back to Westeros again so if this show
ever does get made and we see what is
happening with Jon Snow after he was
exiled Beyond the Wall we may see some
of his old friends and family again as
well I believe this show would be even
more successful than House of the Dragon
because it would essentially be a season
9 of Game of Thrones and as we all know
that was the show that had the most
amount of fans another show HBO has been
developing is known as the nine voyages
or the sea snake a reference to the
adventures of a young Lord Corliss
valerion one of the most famous and
richest men of his day I also think this
show has a great shot of getting made
now that house of the Dragon has seen so
much success with its first season House
of the Dragon is now making Game of
Thrones fans familiar with this
character but that series is only
showing us what happened later in his
life the nine voyages also known as the
sea snake would show us all of the
Amazing Adventures he went on that would
eventually give him his name and his
family's wealth I think this show could
be a lot of fun because we would finally
see all of the other amazing locations
all around the realm HBO has already
hired a writer to draw up its first
season but outside of that they haven't
released any new official developments
another one of the shows HBO has been
developing is known as 10 000 ships set
roughly one thousand years before the
events of Game of Thrones now based on
what we know so far this show would be
sort of similar to the sea snake whereas
this series would focus on a key figure
within westerosi Legend and that is the
founder of Dorne known as nymeria
nymeria who was an ancestor of the
westerosi house Martell and house Dane
led the refugees to find a new home on
Dorne by gathering them onto thousands
of ships although many do believe that
number was drastically inflated once The
Fleets arrived at Dorne nymeria had all
10 000 ships burned so her followers
would know there was no more running
after their new settlement all of you
have heard the name before because as
you all know this is where Arya got the
name for her direwolf not only that but
there was also a mention of her in House
of the dragon's first season during the
scene with rhaenyra and Dallas sen HBO
most likely threw that scene in there as
a way to set up this show assuming they
ever finish it once again HBO already
does have a writer for this series but
outside of that they haven't released
any new official announcements another
show HBO has been developing has a lot
of fans excited because it's Bay based
on some of George R Martin's other
well-known and well-written novellas a
night of the Seven Kingdoms also known
as The Adventures of Duncan egg will be
set roughly 90 years before the main
show now fans of Game of Thrones can
look to Martin's novellas as a roadmap
for what should happen in this show like
I said said about 90 years before the
Game of Thrones series Begins the Duncan
egg novellas Follow The Adventures of
dunk the lowly Knight and future lore
commander of the kingsguard sir Duncan
the tall and his Squire egg the Future
King aegon Targaryen as Westeros
recovers from the blackfyre Rebellion
which was another war that saw
targaryens fighting targaryens like an
House of the Dragon Duncan egg follow
the sprawling landscape competing in
tournaments to earn their daily bread
and often happening upon historical
events it almost sounds like the
Westeros version of Forrest Gump HBO is
also developing some animated shows
based on the works of George RR Martin
on his not a Blog website George R
Martin said over on the animated side
well I'm not allowed to say most of
what's Happening except to say that
things are moving very fast and I love
love love some of the art that I'm
seeing and wait come to think of it the
news leaked several months ago that one
of the animated shows would be set in
E.T that's accurate our working name for
the show is the Golden Empire and we
have a great young writer on that one as
well and I think the art and animation
will be gorgeous I would let all of you
know more if I could but I don't think I
can say a word about the other animated
shows not yet so it actually sounds like
they have three or more animated shows
in development although I cannot confirm
more than what George R Martin has
already said now like the series about
the long night HBO was also working on
another show set in flea bottom of
King's Landing however that show is no
longer in development as of right now it
seems their main focus is on Jon Snow
the sea snake nymeria Duncan egg and the
handful of animated shows you just heard
about if I find out any more information
I will let all of you know right away
I'm always looking for new updates every
single day so with that being said make
sure you subscribe so you're always the
first to know whenever I release a new
video about anything regarding Game of
Thrones House of the Dragon A Song of
Ice and Fire The Winds of Winter or
anything else under the George R Martin
umbrella as always I want to thank all
of you for watching another video I hope
all of you have a great day I will see
you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign